il ya deux manières de voir l'iran il y
à celle qui consiste à analyser la
politique menée par le chat avec ses
côtés positifs
l'expansion économique le développement
industriel mais aussi avec ses aspects
négatifs le refus des libertés ou bien
l'omniprésence d'une police politique
très sévère et puis il ya aussi la
méthode touristique là également il ya
deux méthodes celle du touriste à faible
budget qui se contentent des petits
hôtels et qui est donc en contact plus
direct avec la population
ou bien celle du touriste sans souci
pour ces derniers le souverain iranien
vient de créer un petit paradis le ciel
y est généralement bleu la mer assez
chaude et les palaces fourmillent et
l'on peut même y perdre un peu d'argent
aux casinos ce nouveau paradis pour gens
fortunés c'est l'île de kish
c'est il a été inauguré en décembre et
patrick poivre d'arvor ac christian
giroux ont voulu voir à quoi ressemblait
l'iran des milliardaires
ce petit bout d'île perdu dans le golfe
persique cinq chaînes de télévision dont
deux programmes entièrement fabriqué
pour et par qui il ya cinq ans ici il
n'y avait que des pierres des bergers et
des moutons 100 kilomètres carrés de
semis désert aujourd'hui à grand renfort
de dollars on y fait pousser du gazon
pour un golf qui n'en est encore qu'à
son premier trou et pour pousser il faut
de l'eau là encore il suffit d'une pompe
à pétrodollars cela donne ses tubulures
à la beaubourg c'est une usine de
désalinisation des arabes y travaillent
sous la direction d'ingénieurs israël
tout ça pour quelques centaines de
privilégiés déversé deux fois par mois
par un concorde affrété de paris sur un
aéroport construit tout exprès pour lui
d'avoir une erreur pas besoin de visa
une et qu'ils soient libres affaires
mondiales sans taxes doubt août et des
taxes et j'avais à vaquer à 20 minutes
de dubaï à 10 minutes de bahreïn à une
demi-heure de
une heure de rien une heure et demie de
ryad je crois une heure et mitterrand
les gens qui veulent discuter peut venir
ici de la bonne at-elle affirmé
pour l'instant ils ne sont encore qu'une
poignée bien protégé bien dorées sur
fond d'or noir dans ce détroit d'ormuz
il passe dix pétroliers par heure il est
stratégique
c'est aussi une base militaire mais les
touristes ne savent pas le chat il ya un
palais le petit prince aussi le même en
réduction la shahbanou est la seule à
avoir le droit de se déplacer dans l'île
à moto avec ses gardes du corps ou en
voiture électrique
mais n'allez pas lui parler de snobisme
de ghettos de luxe c'est paraît-il tout
bénéfice pour l'économie iranienne aux
habitants de ce qu'il vient sur ce que
le progrès qui arrive dans une île où
les gens vivaient que simplement de
petits commerce de la pêche sur ça va
les aider à améliorer leur niveau de vie
seul à bord a fait et s'il ya des gens
qui vous font le reproche de dire c'est
trop de luxe au milieu d'un pays qui
reste à payer en voie de développement
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez je leur
répondrai que bon c'est un endroit de
luxe où sont les gens qui est de
l'argent puisse venir dépenser leur
argent ici c'est pour ça que nous avons
créé ce complexe et l'argent que les
gens vont dépenser va être bénéfice du
pays bien sûr
et du luxe il y en a à revendre les plus
grands couturiers parisiens s'y sont
déplacées pas de pharmacie pas
d'épicerie dans l'île mais les grands
noms de la couture de l'orfèvrerie de la
bijouterie ça c'est la griffe française
on va chercher à l'étranger ce qu'il ya
de mieux de plus chic
résultat les chèques arabes et les
princes d'iran se sont arrachés des
villas à 1000 $ le mètre carré
c'est à dire toutes équipées 100 à 150
millions de francs
autour d'un bon buffet à la française on
espère bien qu'ils seront traités d
affaires et que les occidentaux pourront
enfin rencontrer les rois du pétrole
parait-il insaisissable sinon et bien il
reste le casino avec des croupiers qui
sont des croupières et anglaises se sont
dit on les meilleurs on a bien prévu
aussi un terrain de polo mais il faut
déjà construire des boks à air
conditionné pour les chevaux bref comme
on dit et pas vraiment à la portée de
tout le monde
mais si c'est bon pour les affaires je
ne reviens